you're almost done Ryan last question
[Music]
hey welcome to a special Thanksgiving
edition of everyday I'm des hey Ryan you
wanna tell him why it's special welcome
to the Carolina Reaper sauce challenge a
on a very special Thanksgiving edition
of learnin and burnin all right so you
can sell Ryan is pretty excited to be
doing this in this episode he is going
to be consuming some of this Carolina
Reaper hot sauce which is the hottest
pepper on planet Earth it's one under
pepper spray on the Scoville scale yeah
so don't get it in your eyes before this
you've done habanero yeah last time for
Halloween we did the ghost pepper candy
challenge that's precisely yeah and we
did habanero once when we didn't record
it it was funny but this is the Guinness
Book World Record certified hottest
peppers it says on the side that has a
Scoville rating of one point four seven
million stupid also to explain the game
to everybody what happens is I eat
something hot and then I try to learn
something and Nate is a real-life
sociology doctor is the ash and he's
asked me a bunch of questions while I
try not to vomit on Hannah after Ryan
reads from the card and learns the
information about today's topic he will
then have to answer a series of
questions only once he gets all the
questions correct will he be given the
sweet relief of a carton of milk Hannah
as always you're on milk duty I really
don't want to do this one I think he
really means that okay this is my first
time carving a turkey this is gonna be
embarrassing any any tips how long you
do it go with being a turkey which
that's the worst car vibe around show
them what you did
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
that I got a piece of Turkey
looks like the turkey went in for a
biopsy check it out Ryan please hold the
plate I don't really don't what you want
the fork a knife okay oh I can smell it
from here
Oh baby boy
are you ready right is what we're doing
it smells so bad from here I want you to
know that I love you and I believe in
you please eat the pepper oh it's in
there
today's one is the Treaty of Canada
gasps Ryan please read the card the
dream can dude is currently on display
at the Smithsonian he's treating
designed after the American
Revolutionary War between the Grand
Council of the Six Nations and the
president George Washington
representative United States of America
tradies more than 300 graphite reason I
was a u.s. expanded territory and have
led to many broken promises demanded
American Indians the treaty also it's
known as the Pickering tree here in the
calculator has actively recognized by
the United States and the nations one
hundred confers II however in the 1960
10,000 acres treaty okay Thank You Ryan
are you feeling don't touch your eyes
it's pepper spray your eyes are watering
Ryan do you think that has to do with
the hot sauce you just say question
number one initial thoughts
bruja question to the treaty was between
the USA and the Grand Council of the Six
Nations named one of the six Indian
tribes Coons oh damn nope picture here's
a hint Daniel day-lewis your brain
second oil before that Abraham Lincoln
he was in a movie called the last of the
age of New York Chris is helping out but
those chemicals so bad for the Scoville
scale rates spiciness how many Scoville
units would you guess you're feeling in
this Reaper right now obviously if we
said the number early early and really
in for
questions if I wanted to see the
physical treaty today we're what are you
going to do this Thanksgiving to make up
for the past broken promises of the
white man
[Applause]
studies show that Black Friday causes
spikes in air pollution and plastic
waste no worries it compensates by
killing off one carbon producing human
in a ritual stampede no worries
they're probably happier living is bad
about 200 million pounds of Turkey will
be thrown out during the Thanksgiving
holiday season no worries considering
about 300 million pounds was inedible
thanks mom
how's your relationship with your mom no
worries the United States is the number
one trash producing country in the world
no worries they can't keep making Kevin
James sitcoms forever
thanks everyone for spending your
Thanksgiving with me here in the
everyday I'm day studio look at the
space it's so aggressive and you're good
at that
Oh who wants a leg anyone want some of
that saucy I don't want to try try me a
little cut me a little piece of the meat
just a little piece that's how you you
see what he just did they you see what
he just did
that's how you carve a turkey
[Music]